bonsoir françois gabart et merci
énormément d'être avec nous depuis 16
heures vous enchaînez les interviews
avec une facilité déconcertante
vous avez été seul en mer 78 jours
comment avez vous vécu le retour sur
terre
ce moment vous êtes accueilli par des
dizaines de milliers de personnes aux
sables d'olonne
mais la transition est brutale mais
tellement belle c'est vrai que après
avoir vécu comme ça tout seul sur un
bateau pendant trois mois avec toutes
les difficultés que ça et on arrivait en
on voit toute cette foule qui bat qu'à
rêver avec nous qui a qu'à vibrer je
pense pendant pendant ces trois mois de
course et ça fait chaud au coeur ça fait
plaisir merci à toutes les personnes qui
sont venus aujourd'hui sur le chenal des
sables parce que ma grâce à vous j'ai pu
vivre un moment exceptionnel
on vous remercie aussi françois gabart
surtout vous vous êtes aujourd'hui entré
dans la légende
on a entendu plein de compliments
notamment sur votre simplicité votre
humilité
certains vous comparent à eric tabarly
est-ce que vous avez un petit peu peur
de devenir un héros
non je crois pouvoir perdre et ça non je
fais simplement du bateau j'essaie de
faire le du bateau le mieux possible
après ben voilà ce qui se dit autour
c'est ça peut éventuellement là en
l'occurrence ça serait ça ne serait que
flatteur donc ça ne me fait pas peur ce
qui nous frappe chez vous c'est que
depuis le début vous avez le sourire
qu'avez-vous appris sur vous pendant ce
tour du monde en solitaire
j'ai appris qu'on était capable de faire
énormément de choses tout seul sur un
bateau j'ai appris que on était capable
de d'aller très vite d'avoir des coups
durs et puis de 2,2 passes et au delà de
tout ça de trouver de l'énergie au fond
de soi et puis et puis être fatigué à
nouveau mais ils ont retrouvé encore de
l'énergie
j'ai appris voilà que bach un bonhomme
tout seul sur un bateau était capable de
faire plein de choses et c'est plutôt
très très agréable mais il ya eu des
moments vous avez craqué
craquez craquer au point de ne pas
franchir l'arrivée non les moments
difficiles oui évidemment il ya des
moments difficiles c'est normal mais
voilà j'ai réussi à faire face à chaque
fois à respirer un grand coup puis à
repartir à l'attaqué parce qu'il fallait
fallait rien lâcher
il ya armelle là qui vient d'arriver et
le bruit derrière mais mais voilà là la
course a été très serré avec lui pour
les mêmes quand on arrive à terre là on
avait une compétition qui nous
permettait pas de se libérer et comment
vous avez vécu ce duel
cette compétition avec armel le cléac'h
gelé très bien vécu enfin c'était
difficile je le cache pas mais je pense
qu'on a vraiment eu pour les
compétiteurs que nous sommes tous les
deux je connais bien armelle je sais que
c'est un compétiteur je le suis aussi
on a eu de la chance le privilège
immense d'avoir une une régate à deux
bateaux pendant pendant des semaines et
ça c'est vraiment une chance énorme
je suis très heureux parce qu'en plus
les gagner donc forcément ça ça facilite
un petit peu le jugement mais je pense
qu armel a aussi vécu un beau moment de
voir la commande compétition et et c'est
c'est vraiment vraiment beau à voir et
j'ai hâte de vous quitter après pour
aller les féliciter
elle est allée serrer allez-y foncez
foncé rejoindre votre ami votre copain
armel le cléac'h merci mille fois et
bravo encore
on voit d'ailleurs un ces images en
direct qui nous parviennent des sables
d'olonne de l'arrivée ça y est il est
sur terre d'armel le cléac'h qui a donc
lui aussi réalisé un tour du monde en
moins de 80 jours